MGM very recently made contact with side
Trek and they started to confirm a few
little bits of information I have now
asked a very important question
and they've answered
kind of
welcome to soundtrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so last week I was able to tell you that
a representative of MGM actually
somebody that works immediately for
quite a high up executive got in touch
with Sidetrack they wanted to start an
open relationship a discussion with us
and apparently because I'm now a
Stargate influencer I'm not but they
think I am so I'm not going to argue
with them they wanted to have sort of
like an open and honest conversation
they wanted to start getting a little
bit of positivity out there before the
announcement of their Stargate project
now there's a link for the video it'll
be a person
and you can go and check that out I have
actually a video call with this person
but it was very last minute and I didn't
really have chance to ask him any
questions so I've emailed them in the
week and said look am I allowed to sort
of you know ask a couple of things and
they've said yeah go for it we will
answer what we can so I sent them an
email
at Sidetrack we've heard rumors for some
time that the Revival will be a
continuation but the perhaps some
changes to what we know as Stargate
would be permitted by the creators can
you reassure fans that the hard reboot
is not an option and today I got a
response
at MGM and Amazon pictures we strive to
create exciting and new TV movies to do
that we have to trust the creative
people chosen to bring those shows and
movies to life we have though of course
done significant investigations into
what the fans want and expect a beloved
franchise like Stargate cannot be
rebooted as if those shows never
happened Our intention is to respect
what has come before while also
respecting the Creative Vision of our
creators bringing it so that is a very
simple we neither confirm nor denied no
I don't think that's quite fair but they
are basically saying that they do not
wish to go the hard reboot direction
that that is actually not what fans want
and it's not what they want
but this then goes into something that
we've actually been telling you for some
time that we even though we're not going
to get a hard reboot or even a soft
reboot we are looking at a continuation
that there will be changes and it might
be sort of like a hybrid reboot now this
is very similar to what they've done
with the new Trek that the creators have
been allowed to change things now I
would argue change way too much but they
were still allowed that the actual
people at Paramount said to kurtzman and
his team you are the creative Direction
you choose lots of these things but with
some restrictions obviously now we
believe that Mark Fergus has actually
been tapped up to do a Bible of Stargate
now we believe this was done very early
on in the development process so that
whichever Creator is then picked to
actually do the movie TV series whatever
had some direction in what they're
allowed to change and what they weren't
what is canon and what is Up For Debate
what this official Source here from MGM
is telling us though is that they will
actually trust the creative people that
they put in charge of the movie or the
TV series that they need to allow them
to express themselves to actually get
what they feel and they envisage for the
show onto the screen now I actually can
kind of understand that because look
they even did that with Brad Wright when
it went from the movie to the TV series
they had to develop that TV series they
had to change certain things from the
movie now a lot of those changes have
created the fan theory that actually
Stargate O'Neill with two L's is
actually a different Universe from the
original movie and that's why there are
so many changes the go award for example
are very different in the TV series than
they were in the movie so it may be that
the new creators are allowed to do the
same thing that they are allowed to
develop the new show along the lines
that they see fit to a point
hopefully the Bible that has been agreed
at Amazon and MGM with Mark Fergus and
his team is pretty strict and that they
are then made to keep to it this is what
they did with Star Trek the Next
Generation Gene Roddenberry created a
Bible of the TV show Brandon Braga then
when he took over as the main man at
Star Trek for the Next Generation
Voyager Deep Space Nine and Enterprise
stuck to that Bible religiously now
kurtzman threw that Bible out and peed
on it and that's what we want to avoid
we want a TV show that actually still
feels like Stargate I completely
understand the need to trust the new
creators to trust the new directors the
writers Etc
and that we need a show that still is a
bit of them as well
and at the end of the day they're going
to be judged on the results at the end
of the day we are more than a decade
down the road from when we lost SGU the
world has changed the way TV is made has
changed and look there are going to be
some changes that reflect that just
things like special effects are way
different and that is going to affect
again the way the show is made what
people expect from their television has
changed and that will affect the way the
show is made as well
so expect changes expect things to be a
little bit different
but let's hope that's different as in
the way the next generation was brought
to us not different in the way that
kurtzman Trek was brought to us I'm
reassured to a point by this statement I
think it does say exactly what we've
believed for some time about Amazon's
intentions and that in a way it makes
sense but I'd love to know what you
think does this reassure you or does
this make you actually a little bit more
nervous that if they get the wrong
creators we're going to get another
rings of power problem
or actually do you think look Amazon and
MGM they've got to pick the right people
but then they've got to trust them to
make the show themselves
too many cooks do spoil the broth and
what we really don't want is TV in a
movie Executives sticking their noses in
every five minutes because that's when
really stupid decisions in the past have
been made I can name 100 moves up top of
my head where decisions were forced on
directors by Executives that just
completely ruined the whole thing
Amazon don't seem to want to do that
and is that a good thing
we're gonna have to wait and see but I'd
love for you to get into the comments
and tell me what you think
there will also be a poll on the
Community page go and check it out to
ask again whether you think this is a
good idea or not if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and you get
to see them for a small contribution
each month that really supports the
channel a day before everybody else and
there's no adverts so bonus all round
also you can go to sidetrack.co.uk that
has our dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our videos and
we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest so go and
check it out as always please stay safe
I'll see you next time
[Music]